did you know that a charmingly sweet
sports movie starring anthony hopkins of
all people is available to watch on
youtube oh yeah it's also free curious
to know what it is keep watching for
this title and 23 more
few war stories are as harrowing as all
quiet on the western front and its start
grim grace comes across perfectly in
this 1979 television film the movie
follows young paul baumer alongside his
friends and his comrades in arms through
their world war 1 service paul enters
the war full of romantic idealism his
passion for a noble quest stoked by a
teacher who notably has no plans to
volunteer for the fight he soon learns
the bloody and bitter reality of war
which he experiences as a grinding
pointless horror his bond with some of
his fellow soldiers provides the only
bright spot and that becomes its own
torment as his friends die off all
around him they've amputated my leg
could be worse
the film is obviously bleak but it's
also beautifully crafted furthermore the
acting helps convey the staggering human
cost of the war magnifying the movie's
effectiveness it's painful to watch but
it's worth it
this early slasher is a dark atmospheric
masterpiece black christmas features an
incredible cast full of familiar faces
including olivia hussey margot kidder
and horror icon john saxon given its
solid cast the film creates characters
who are richer and more realistic than
the stalk and stache norm olivia hussey
stars as chess a serious young woman in
the midst of a personal crisis on top of
that her sorority house keeps getting
obscene phone calls
the more jaded girls can dismiss and
even ridicule the unknown caller's heavy
breathing and grotesque advances but he
soon escalates the wild shrieks
different voices and threats of murder
expanded his act
when sweet responsible claire turns up
missing it kicks off a police
investigation one that eventually
reveals part of the terrifying mystery
behind the phone calls while time has
lessened the impact of the biggest twist
in black christmas it definitely hasn't
diminished the film's definitely handled
characterization well-incorporated humor
moody atmosphere and strong sense of
place so what about the scares put it
this way there are scenes and images
here that will have a permanent place in
your nightmares you'll never think of a
plastic bag the same way again the
ending is the perfect ambiguous cherry
on top over the years the film has
become a cult for classic that's popular
with fans and critics alike it's earned
both a spot on bravo's list of scariest
movie moments and retrospective articles
praising its feminist overtones
when conspiracy theorists insist that
the moon landing was all an elaborate
well-funded hoax there's one movie they
like to point to capricorn 1 a paranoid
70s thriller where nasa's strong arms
its astronauts into faking a mars
mission just so the money keeps flowing
we do not claim this planet in the name
of america we claim it in the name of
all the people of the planet earth
obviously the moon landing was real and
capricorn 1 is absolutely fiction in
spite of its lackluster early reviews
however the film is a satisfying and
well-constructed thriller with a strong
cast that includes heavy hitters like
hal hallbrook karen black and elliott
gould fans of movies like the parallax
views should certainly check it out
the 1985 television adaptation of death
of a salesman made an impressive showing
at the emmys collecting an award for its
art direction as well as outstanding
acting in a mini-series or special
awards for dustin hoffman and john
malkovich as well as a whole slew of
nominations the story is a small scale
tragedy of traveling salesman willie
lowman whose dreams of success have
never really come to fruition
i'm going off the road
willie is slipping into senility and his
family is struggling to deal with it
even as he keeps judgment upon them his
relationship with his sons happy and
biff takes center stage as the young men
grapple with the weight of his
expectations the original play is a
classic for a reason and this remarkably
strong adaptation makes you feel like
you're seeing it performed live and by
some of the best actors of the last few
decades
if you like kaiju movies you should know
in advance that destroy all monsters
isn't just one of the best kaiju movies
it's also one of the most kaiju movies
featuring an epic clash of 11 separate
monsters the king of all mashups takes
place after all known kaiju have been
safely confined to monster island where
scientists and researchers can study
them unfortunately when aliens start
mind controlling the scientists this
means it's all too easy for them to
unleash the monsters on the world cities
will fall until earth gives in needless
to say people don't give up that easily
and soon it's a battle of our monsters
against their monsters destroy all
monsters provides plenty of kaiju action
and satisfaction while also fully
acknowledging that since this is the 9th
godzilla movie everyone is really fond
of these guys by now and don't want to
see them go down
the endless is an ambitious and
beautiful sci-fi horror film that makes
the most of its modest budget instead of
pure spectacle you get thoughtful and
innovative chills the movie is a
companion piece to resolution also by
directors justin benson and aaron
morehead the two films enrich each other
but they can both be watched as
standalones of the two the endless is a
shade more complex it concentrates on
two brothers justin and aaron who have
lived marginal and unsatisfying lives
ever since justin forced them to break
away from the camp arcadia the cult they
grew up in
aaron misses the easy life camaraderie
and sense of belonging and when he and
justin receive a video from camp arcadia
he seizes on the excuse to go back for
at least a brief visit once there the
tension between the brothers amps up
with aaron embracing the place while
justin can't stop wondering about all
its impossibilities why doesn't anyone
there seem to age why is there a second
moon in the sky who or what is leaving
them photographs and videos and what
does it all mean the answers are clever
and sometimes terrifying especially in
the scene where justin finds people who
are also trapped in the area but not
having an idyllic camp arcadia
experience this is a movie that will
linger long after its credits roll
[Music]
four lions is a dark and daring
satirical thriller with plenty of
politically sharp criticism of both its
fanatical would-be terrorists and the
world that rouses their ire security
guard omar played by riz ahmed and his
friends are frustrated angry committed
idealistic and sometimes incredibly
confused and incompetent they want to
express their beliefs to the world
explosively there's just one
complication they're not exactly the
most talented terrorists in the world
just as a start they have trouble
picking targets and let's just say that
their skills with handling explosives
could use a little fine tuning equal
parts exciting and insightful four lions
takes a lot of risks and makes them pay
off in spades
chloe is just a little girl but that
wouldn't matter to the dangerous
government agency that keeps an eye out
for abnormals and tries to capture or
kill them both her parents and
grandfather are abnormals no wonder her
justifiably paranoid father henry who
can slow time always tries to keep her
inside and out of sight he wants to give
her a normal life someday but he's
terrified that she'll meet the same fate
as her mother who is imprisoned in matic
mountain by the ruthless abnormal
defense squad will henry's chances of
keeping chloe safe fall apart when she
makes it into the outside world i
promise i'll listen to you i won't go
outside
moreover is there any hope of rescuing
her mother the superpower elements are
well considered and an immediate draw
but it's how freaks handles them with
skilled acting personal stakes and
realism that really makes the movie
something special gizmodo's review
emphasizes the film's delightful
combination of science fiction and heart
saying the directors stuff freaks with
limitless imagination finding ways to
execute their loftier ambitions it's a
film filled with complex robust ideas
that not only have a unique twist to
them but a realistic grounding that
makes them more relatable and impactful
1954's original godzilla is a classic
for a reason the film features smooth
storytelling strong pacing great early
creature effects and costuming and a
moving sense of how cooperation and
insight can help save the day and
sometimes create new risks most of all
it has a powerful subtext about the
profound cost of nuclear warfare and
experimentation it's not just a good fun
movie it's a meaningful one that really
resonates with people godzilla is the
descendant of a prehistoric sea creature
and is now evolved enough to walk on
land much to humanity's dismay newly
awakened by nuclear testing godzilla is
now rampaging around and across japan
destroying ships and villages and
withstanding everything the country
tries to throw at him it's easy to see
why the movie has aged so well as time
output it more so than in the jokey
sequels this film's godzilla comes off
as a potent and provocative metaphor the
lumbering embodiment of atomic age
anxieties birthed from mankind's own
desire to destroy godzilla is pop art as
purge
dan harmon's community has long been one
of tb's most celebrated comedies the
documentary harmon town like the podcast
that springs from takes the lid off the
show's creator and shows you what's
underneath
uh
this is it
we don't yeah we don't we don't prepare
actually harmon himself takes the lid
off himself over the course of
harmontown he reveals his gifts
insecurities and issues at a
particularly vulnerable time in his life
right after he was fired from his own
show and set adrift for its fourth
season did you did you see it coming
that you were gonna be
like tired i always joked about it yeah
maybe i maybe they got the idea from me
needing to get a handle on a temporarily
community-free life harmon went on the
road with his podcast and did the rambly
live shows that are shown here it's nice
to see harmon at work but the truth is
that the draw here is less the content
he makes and more the man himself it's
not just a kind of sprawling comedy
special it's also a searching
psychological examination a lot is
written about difficult artists but it's
rare that one gets this kind of warm but
open and unsentimental showcase this is
all a lie
as a romantic comedy i could never be
your woman maybe a little uneven but how
can we resist when it boasts two of the
most likable stars in existence michelle
pfeiffer and paul rudd throw in an early
stunningly talented appearance by the
great circa ronan and put director amy
heckerling of clueless fame at the helm
and you're all set for movie night
pfeiffer plays tv executive rosie hansen
who runs a show called you go girl rosie
is 40 in a business that often prefers
women under 30 and is making herself
conscious it also gets in the way of her
new romance with a playful atom a
breakout star on her show and one who is
11 years younger than she is adam
doesn't think their age difference is a
big deal but rosie can't stop worrying
that it's the death knell for their
relationship her insecurity is
definitely not helped by her scheming
secretary who goes to some extreme
lengths to egg on rosie's worries and
get them to split up the illusionist
came out in 2006 so it got overshadowed
by christopher nolan's the prestige now
that the two historical magician movies
are no longer competing for the same
ticket sales though it's fine to call
off the duel and admit that both are
well worth watching the illusionist
takes place in 19th century vienna where
a magician named eisenheim played by
edward norton rises from poor obscure
origins to national fame however his
celebrity comes too late and by the time
he's wealthy enough to be a suitable
match for his true love sophie played by
jessica beale she's already engaged to
the vicious crown prince leopold played
by rufus sewell sophie loves eisenheim
and fears leopold but she doesn't have
much choice in her marriage trying to
break it off results in a horror that
pits eisenheim against leopold in an
elaborate public and illusion-filled
battle for justice that has to be
mediated by chief inspector ol played by
paul giamatti roger ebert notes that the
illusionist succeeds mostly because of
its terrific quartet of central
performances and he reserves special
praise for giamatti writing his
expressions and line readings alone are
worth the price of admission as they
convey all's uncomfortable position on
the horns of a devilish dilemma or his
holmesian delight in assembling another
section of the picture puzzle
if you're a martial arts fan who has
somehow missed 2008's hit ip man and
it's sequels you need to get to youtube
immediately to soak up all the
spectacularly choreographed action if
you're not into martial arts then you'll
be pleased to know that it man doubles
as an engrossing biopic with a talented
and charismatic star for those who don't
know ipman was a wing chun master a
humble but incredibly gifted martial
artist who would eventually go on to
teach bruce lee himself his early years
are brought to incredibly vivid life by
donna yen whose performance here takes
it through the dangers and difficulties
of the chinese-japanese conflict in
world war ii
the film doesn't stint on the horrors he
has to witness and endure but the focus
here is on how despite everything it
persists in showing his skill and
character some of his feats may be a
little exaggerated but they're always
deliciously cinematic
are of course numerous jane eyre
adaptations but we'll always have a soft
spot for 1997's tv film adaptation
starring samantha morton and kieran
hines two consistently great performers
who are at their best here it is as
review cite the silver petticoat notes
an extremely even brutally condensed
adaptation one that pairs a thick novel
down to a mere 108 minutes when
adaptations are this plentiful though
different approaches are welcome you
will find more faithful and
comprehensive takes elsewhere but this
one takes risks that pay off one of the
most controversial aspects is heinz more
abrasive mr rochester heinz issues an
overtly romantic approach until
rochester really begins to soften
towards jane and while his less
attractive beginning wrangled a few fans
it makes the romantic payoff incredibly
satisfying this jane and rochester are
unabashedly flawed and human and it
works
if you throw me out of this house and i
will pound against the door until you
let me in
don't you understand
beautiful delicate and painful the
miseducation of cameron post is an
lgbtq-themed coming-of-age drama about a
young girl sent to a fundamentalist gay
conversion therapy center cameron
doesn't want to be at god's promise and
she pushes back against the center's
stance that her sexual orientation is
sinful wrong and misguided she strives
to maintain a sense of self while
dealing with a process designed to grind
her down and her one real refuge is her
friendship with jane and adam two other
center misfits while cameron goes
through some heartbreaking romantic
struggles it's hard to fall in love with
someone afraid to openly love you back
the main focus here is on the sense of
community she finds and how it enables
her to survive her time in a
fundamentally harmful institution
the classic family drama on golden pond
is realistic warm and human and it isn't
afraid to wear its heart on its sleeve
and risk being called sentimental it's
possible that a lesser cast might make
it tip over into being a cheap
tear-jerker but that's not a problem
when you have catherine hepburn henry
fonda and jane fonda as your central
trio hepburn and fonda play aging
married couple ethel and norman thayer
who were trying to have one more lovely
relaxed summer at golden pond that
prospect is interrupted and complicated
by their adult daughter chelsea who
arrives at the cottage with a new fiance
and teenage soon-to-be stepson in tow
chelsea has a complicated relationship
with her father who she feels tries to
control her life but she needs her
parents to watch 13 year old billy while
she and his father are traveling the
summer becomes an opportunity for
everyone to connect mature and embrace
fleeting joys
parisia tem is an endearing anthology
film that creates a lovely mosaic of
paris the lengthy list of directors 22
and all is excellent in genre spanning
incorporating everyone from joel and
ethan cohen to wes craven their segments
have the same kind of variety switching
easily from drama to comedy and from the
supernatural to the realistic all
anthology films are unavoidably a little
uneven and it's likely that some stories
will work for you and some won't but all
in all this provides plenty of wit
defection and a sense of magic the movie
also makes the most of its short
segments with each story confined to a
type 5 minutes that according to empire
are handled with uncommon grace the best
segment may be the final one directed by
alexander payne where the always great
margot martindale plays an american
tourist ii in the words of critic josh
larson gradually transforms from a clown
to an intimate sympathetic figure it's
expertly handled by both actress and
director and it makes for a wonderful
send-off
the japanese monster movie pantheon
wouldn't be complete without 1956's
rodan in this kaiju classic nuclear
testing brings back a number of immense
prehistoric creatures most notably the
fearsome rodan rodin hatches inside a
mine and soon begins laying waste to
modern society just by following its
instincts for a while it has a
considerable advantage no one knows what
it is both rodan and its mates keep
getting misconstrued as some kind of
aircraft with eyewitnesses unable to
make sense of these enormous winged
creatures
soon enough though humanity rallies and
with clever use of an active volcano
battles back against the beasts like
king kong and godzilla himself rodin has
a kind of pathos it's not malicious it's
just a creature that thanks to troubling
human experiments has awoken in the
wrong era that angle is pivotal to the
movie's success because as tcm notes it
deepens the fun the result is a monster
movie with both heart and thought behind
it
walter hill helms this action-packed
thriller about a national guard squad
lost and overwhelmed in a louisiana
swamp the film stars two terrific actors
keith carradine as pfc spencer empowers
booth as corporal harden the men are
grounded reasonable and often
appealingly cynical but their squad is
mostly unskilled and trigger-happy and
there's no way to avoid getting dragged
into that kind of trouble
oh as you all i quit asking questions
and hall ass
when the soldiers first commandeer
canoes belonging to some of the locals
and then jokingly aggravate them by
firing blanks the situation escalates to
violence and it only worsens from there
soon the men realize that as long as
there is a chance the national guard
members will report the murders the
locals have no intention of letting them
leave the swamp alive bill's commitment
and the actor's naturalism lets the
story go where it wants
barbara stanwick is one of her best
performances in stella dallas a
beautifully performed and
psychologically complex 1937 melodrama
stella is a brash working class woman
who dreams of climbing out of her
assigned role in life and entering into
the world of glamour money and privilege
she's not afraid to stoop to blatant
fortune hunting in her quest either
that's how she lands stephen dallas who
marries her only because his real love
is out of reach adapt myself
give up a few things
well what have i been doing ever since i
met you
their life together is mostly unhappy
and stella can never pass for a natural
member of the elite world she's married
into but the relationship transforms her
forever by giving her a daughter laurel
stella's devotion to laurel is genuine
and unselfish and it completely
overhauls her priorities she goes from
focusing on her own social advancement
to designing strategies to make laurel's
life as easy and happy as possible the
only problem is that she gradually
starts to suspect that she will always
be too unsophisticated to belong in the
future she wants for laurel in fact her
role as laurel's mother might even keep
that future from happening at all
tag is bizarre beautiful and confounding
and it builds the huge revelations and a
spectacular climax the heroine is an
ordinary high school student who's
seemingly doomed to be the sole survivor
of multiple gory and fantastical events
she's surrounded by other girls who get
cut down like weeds while she keeps
going even flickering through multiple
realities and scenarios finding a way
out of her predicament means finding an
action so unexpected that it defies fate
and effectively breaks the rule of the
universe and the movie doesn't stop
there tag is what happens when you blend
inception with sucker punch and anyone
intrigued by that description is in for
a treat
the smart adrenaline-fueled train to
busan might be one of the best zombie
movies it offers a nearly unbeatable
combination of vivid characters in
zombie mayhem and the tight setting the
aforementioned train to busan is a great
gimmick that ups attention and gives the
action a unique framework there's really
nothing bad here and the movie ties it
all together with some strong emotional
storytelling involving the various
families on board critic josh larson
singled out the film's camera work as a
particularly important element writing
it takes precise advantage of this
confined space emphasizing the
survivor's limited options as larson
points out this brilliant use of setting
allows train to busan to deliver a quote
cleverly concentrated shot of zombie
terror
retching struggles over child custody
are just as current and affecting now as
they were in 1897 when henry james
published his classic novel what mazie
knew and this 2012 adaptation updates
the story setting while keeping its pain
insight and emotional resonance maisy is
the quiet six-year-old daughter of beal
and susanna two phenomenally selfish and
self-involved people who spend much of
their marriage at each other's throats
when they split up macy's living
situation becomes a kind of tug-of-war
rope and a game neither really wants to
win they both just want each other to
lose in fact the two people in the movie
who genuinely care about maisie and
attempt to look after her are her step
parents lincoln and margot they're the
only ones who don't lose track of macy's
best interests in the midst of all this
one-upmanship and relationship turmoil
remaking a new kind of family out of the
ashes of the old may be the best round
forward as hard as it is to watch such
an evocative portrayal of a child's
emotional agony there's a light at the
end of the tunnel and that factor plus
the brilliant performances make it easy
to recommend what maisie knew
the world's fastest indian is a sweet
down-to-earth sports film that thrives
on the charming lead performance of
anthony hopkins since some of hopkins
best roles have been imposing
charismatic villains it's easy to forget
just how good he can be on a small scale
here he's burt an eccentric elderly
motorbike enthusiast one who has already
established a kind of fame at home in
new zealand and now wants to take on
america in particular the race at the
bonneville salt flats you know at
bolivar things go real fast
circumstances including his own health
keep conspiring against him but burnt
soldiers off
come on
[Applause]
the movie has a pleasant episodic
structure with bert's long road trip
punctuated not only by his various
obstacles but also by the various allies
he makes along the way giving us plenty
of gently endearing portraits of a wide
cast of characters effectively this is a
heartwarming quirky travelogue with a
gratifying sports movie ending
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]